[موسيقى]
والدي جاء من عائلتين مختلفتين نحن نعود
للقبائل ونؤمن بانه لا يمكن الزواج من
القبيله الواحده لانهم يعتقدون ان لديهم
ذات الدي ان اي امي من قبيله السلحفاه
ووالدي من قبيله نهر البارد اما اجداد
فكانوا من طلاب المدارس الداخليه التي
اسسوا انفسهم فيها خسرنا كثيرا من لغتنا
لان اجدادنا لا يتحدثون لغتهم الاصليه
نحاول التقاط بعض الكلمات من هنا وهناك
حتى تبقى لكننا لم نتمكن من تاسيس اللغه
وتمكينها لذلك لغه انتهت
[موسيقى]
عندما نرقص نرقص للخالق نرقص للارض
ونشكرهم على ما قدموه لنا رقصتنا اشبه
بالدعاء للناجين ولعائلاتنا ومجتمعنا من
ضمن عاداتنا ان نجتمع مع بعضنا لنرفع
الصلوات من اجل الشفاء وليس من الضروري ان
نلتقط الصور اثناء الدعاء
[موسيقى]
النهر بالنسبه لنا السر نحن نؤمن بان
الخالقه ما نحن هذه النار لتحمينا وان
الخالق يحافظ على هذه النار
[موسيقى]